Guten Morgen Lenos.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik Folge dreihundertzwanzig vom fünften,
November zweitausendneunzehn. Ähm wir haben ja schon angekündigt, dass wir
eventuell eine längere Pause machen, weil Tim verhindert ist, aber die Themen sind wichtig und dringend, deswegen sitze ich heute hier,
in der Berliner Seabays zusammen mit Elke Steven vom Verein digitale Gesellschaft. Hallo Ecker.
Wir sind im Sound Lab,
Der Seaways, ein Ort, den ich gar nicht kannte. Ähm ich habe ehrlich gesagt den Eindruck, dass die Seaways unglaublich viele Räume hat, die ich vielleicht noch gar nicht kenne, ist auf jeden Fall ein riesiger Hackerspace in Berlin und ich muss jetzt fast sagen, ich weiß gar nicht genau
Seit wann es die CEBAS gibt, ob es irgendwie ein oder zwei Jahrzehnte würde ich vorsichtig schätzen. Ich schau mal ganz kurz in der.
In der Wikipedia. Zweitausendvier. Nee, seit zweitausendvier. Nee, jetzt ist es seit Zeit neunzehnhundert.
Fünfundneunzig wurde die Seaways gegründet. Herr Je, meine Güte.
Okay, interessant. Also ein äh Hackerspace mit äh sehr viel äh Geschichte in Berlin und äh das, was den meisten Leuten wahrscheinlich bekannt ist, ist die äh gemeinhin ähm als,
Fernsehturm oder auch als Achsel bezeichnete Antenne der Seaways.
Danny Seaways ist eine Raumstation, die unter Berlin äh größtenteils unterirdisch ist und was noch oben rausschaut ist diese Antenne, die ja natürlich auch das Wahrzeichen Berlins geworden ist. Und hier richtet ihr regelmäßig.
Den netzpolitischen Abend aus. So auch heute.
Genau, immer am ersten Dienstag im Monat machen wir den netzpolitischen Abend hier auf der Seabase ähm und heute ist der siebenundachtzigste.
Netzpolitischer Abend da ist auch schon viel zusammen gekommen. Ähm es ist immer ein breites Spektrum von Themen, die wir da aufnehmen heute Abend äh sind es auch wieder vier Vorträge
zu ganz unterschiedlichen Themen die Frage, was brauchen wir eigentlich für ein umfassendes Hinweisgeberschutzgesetz, das heißt es geht um Wissenlauer
es geht um die Ervidenz, also die ganze Frage, wie Daten demnächst abgefragt werden können, auch im Ausland. Ähm,
Es geht dadrum äh wie die Macht der Digitalkonzerne beschränkt werden könnte durch den
Und äh es geht um die Aufsicht über Algorithmen äh um welche Ethikrichtlinien oder Regulierungen da sinnvoll sind.
Das heißt, da ist richtig viel inhaltlich, was ähm.
Was uns davor absteht, aber es ist immer auch ein sehr schönes Treffen von Leuten, die in diesem ganzen Umfeld, von Netzpolitik, Digitalisierung,
sich mit den Fragen beschäftigen.
Und veröffentlicht werden die Vorträge, die dort stattfinden auch immer auf äh YouTube, wenn ich das richtig sehe und hier von der C-Base auch aufgezeichnet und live gestreamt, ne.
Genau. Das heißt, es gibt einen Livestream äh ab zwanzig Uhr fünfzehn und äh ab morgen Abend sind dann die ähm Videos hoffentlich bei uns auf dem, auf unserem,
YouTube-Kanal von digitale Gesellschaft veröffentlicht äh und dann kann man die auch auf unserer,
Internetseite, digitale Gesellschaft Punkt DE finden.
Wunderbar, da müssen wir nur noch äh weil wir, ich weiß gar nicht, es ist einige Zeit her, dass wir jemanden von digitale Gesellschaft im Podcast hatten, deswegen kriegst du auch nochmal Kurzgelegenheit, äh digitale Gesellschaft vorzustellen.
Ja, wir sind zweitausendzehn gegründet und.
Nehmen alle, also wir haben natürlich ein positives Verhältnis zur Digitalisierung, aber wir wollen, dass die so äh
umgesetzt wird, dass tatsächlich die Grundrechte und Menschenrechte gewahrt werden, dass es Demokratie fördernd ist und nicht abträglich äh und deshalb greifen wir,
Die Themen, die in diesem Umfeld sind, immer wieder aufbleiben, aber vor allem auch an vielen Themen lange dran. Das heißt, äh welche Daten werden wie äh geschützt oder nicht geschützt, wie sieht es mit dem
Datenschutzrecht aus und äh aber eben innere Sicherheitsgesetze sind die, die uns immer wieder auch beschäftigen und natürlich die Gesundheitsdaten.
Die Gesundheitsdaten sind auch genau das Thema, warum ich äh,
mich heute hier noch dran gewanzt hab an den netzpolitischen Abend und Fremdpodcast äh und mir in der Seaways ein Soundlab geschnorrt habe, ähm um dich hier noch abzufangen, denn wir wollen heute sprechen,
Zur Digitalisierung, des Gesundheitswesens. Beides Themen, die ich wichtig finde, Gesundheit ist mir wichtig,
Digitalisierung ist mir auch wichtig. Beides zusammenzubringen, wäre wahrscheinlich gar nicht so eine blöde Idee.
Aber äh wir sehen auch hier.
Lauert die Tücke primär wahrscheinlich in Form unseres Gesundheitsministers, dass es ja Jens Spahn und ähm das äh lässt schon mal nicht allzu viel Gutes verhoffen,
Du hast als Sachverständige den Verein digitale Gesellschaft in einer Bundestagsanhörung zu diesem Gesetz vertreten.
Ist erst vor kurzem gewesen, ne? Dieses Gesetz scheint irgendwie so ein bisschen sehr schnell über uns hereinzubrechen. Worum geht's denn primär dabei.
Also,
Jens Spahn macht das ja ein Gesetz nach dem anderen und man könnte jetzt schon über die vergangenen Gesetze auch reden, aber jetzt geht es halt um das Gesetz für eine bessere Versorgung durch Digitalisierung und Innovation. Er versteht eben immer dem so positive
auch zu vergeben, sodass alle denken, das muss ja auch gut sein
und der Entwurf war eigentlich noch viel umfassender, da wollte er noch viel stärker auch die Telematik-Infrastruktur mitregeln, also diese ganze Kommunikation zwischen Patienten und Arzt.
Vereinfacht gesagt ähm und das war dann da waren auch viel zu viele Bedenken auch vom Datenschutzbeauftragten und das hat dann dazu geführt, dass er da Teile rausgenommen hat, immer ankündigt, dass es jetzt auch noch ein.
Noch dieses Jahr geben soll. Jetzt geht es aber mal erst um dieses kurz abgekürzt digitale Versorgungsgesetz. Mhm.
Und das wird diese Woche Donnerstag im Bundestag verhandelt, eventuell nochmal Freitag und dann auch verabschiedet.
Dann soll es eigentlich noch in den Bundesrat gehen. Der Bundesrat hat auch schon einmal dadrüber, ähm,
gestimmt und hat vor allem sehr viele Bedenken, auch berechtigte Bedenken gegen das Gesetz äh zusammengefasst, die die Bundesregierung haben kurz nachdem sie die Bedenken bekommen hat
damit abgehandelt hat, dass es alles nicht so wäre und dass ich damit auch erledigt hätte, was der Bundesrat gesagt hat.
Äh also inhaltliche Auseinandersetzung scheint ja nicht äh stattzufinden oder was.
Nein, die Regierung hat keine Interesse, die sich da noch inhaltlich und,
äh auseinanderzusetzen und der Bundesgesundheitsminister eh nicht. Er hat ja schon mal in seinem Buch von vor drei Jahren gesagt, dass der Datenschutz eher was für Gesunde wäre, aber für die eigentlich auch nicht wirklich, ähm weil das.
Eigentlich alles hinderlich ist.
In welcher Form ist Datenschutz im Gesundheitswesen hinderlich.
Ähm.
Na ja, es gibt natürlich vor allem Interesse dadran, viele Daten zu bekommen, also äh und Daten kann man in viele Richtungen auswerten. Das heißt, der Staat hat ein Interesse da dran, äh
Bevölkerung auch ähm zu gucken, wie was zu steuern ist. Die Krankenversicherungen haben Interesse da dran zu gucken, wo Einsparungen möglich sind,
ähm,
Forschung und natürlich auch die pharmazeutische Forschung hat sowieso Interesse dadran Daten auszuwerten und damit Möglichkeiten zu schaffen,
dieses digitale Versorgungsgesetz schafft vor allem also hat zwei Schwerpunkte glaube ich. Das eine Schwerpunkt ist einmal das ist,
digitale Apps verschrieben werden können danach, also ähm digitale.
Versorgung heißt dann Apps, die irgendwie zum Beispiel eine Kontrolle von Patienten oder Erinnerungsapps oder irgendwie solche Sachen ähm können dann von den Ärzten verschrieben werden,
Aber können nicht nur von den Ärzten verschrieben werden, sondern auch die Krankenkassen können,
zustimmen, dass ein bestimmter Patient Versicherter bei ihnen eine bestimmte App.
Bekommt und die dann von der Krankenkasse finanziert wird.
Äh äh okay, das klingt jetzt erstmal irgendwie.
Offene Weise, nach einer gar nicht so schlechten Idee, wenn man sich jetzt vorstellen könnte, dass eine App irgendwie therapeutische Wirkung entfalten kann.
Aber sollte doch eigentlich zu relativ ernsten Fragen überhaupt führen, was diese App macht, ne? Weil.
Also eine App üblicherweise irgendwo einen Server hat, wo eine ganze Menge Daten gespeichert werden, gibt's da irgendwelche Anforderungen, Datenschutzrechtliche Anforderungen, wie so eine App zu funktionieren hat und wie die dabei anfallenden Daten verwendet werden.
Also es soll natürlich alles irgendwie schon datenschutzrechtlich geprüft werden, aber es ist nicht spezifiziert, was,
verschrieben werden kann. Im Prinzip können Firmen, Apps anbieten,
und in dem ersten Jahr müssen sie auch nicht nachweisen, dass die Apps irgendeinen Nutzen haben, äh können auch selber den Preis bestimmen, aber äh wenn es akzeptiert wird, dann ähm,
können die verschrieben werden und die Krankenkassen bezahlen dafür.
Gibt's da ein Beispiel, was das, was jetzt irgendwie eine App wäre? Also ich stelle mir das sehr äh.
Also na ja, Adam ist die, die gerade am stärksten so diskutiert wird oder am aktuellsten ähm,
Wie wie war's vorher? Ähm da die haben sechs.
Prüfungen zu auf Datenschutz hin bestanden, also von daher glauben sie eigentlich, dass sie guten Datenschutz gewährleistet haben. Mhm.
Ähm aber es hat sich jetzt äh rausgestellt, dass die eben zusammenarbeiten mit den großen Firmen und,
Daten abfließen, wenn man schon nur die die App aufruf.
Ja, das war, also ich gut Vivi hatte, glaube ich, damals,
primär einmal Queds hatte da die ganzen Tracker schon allein in der App gefunden Martin Schiersig hat da noch eine Reihe an Schwachstellen in der App gefunden, hat darüber beim letzten,
Communication Congress äh gesprochen.
Ähm ich frage mich jetzt, was also das scheint mir aber noch nicht wirklich eine App zu sein, die mir verschrieben werden kann, oder? Also ähm.
Also.
Hierbei bei Ader, was ich jetzt finde ist, dass man da also eine App, die von Doktoren und Wissenschaftlerinnen und sonstigen Leuten entwickelt worden, wer die, wo man irgendwie Symptome eingibt und die sagt einem dann, was man hat.
Oder also das kommt mir alles sehr sehr ähm komisch vor.
Also es ist nicht geklärt, welche Apps tatsächlich verschrieben werden können, aber es gibt natürlich Apps, die einen daran erinnern, dass man, wann man die Medikamente nehmen muss. Mhm. Also so ganz einfache Sachen
aber es gibt eben auch Apps, die.
Psychisch kranke an irgendwas erinnern können oder was machen können oder messen können. Mhm. Es gibt die Möglichkeiten,
zum Beispiel, wenn jemand Diabetes hat äh daran zu erinnern, wenn äh Blutpegel so.
Wird, dass sie eigentlich medikamentämen konnte. Also es gibt ja eine Menge an Kontrollfunktionen, Körperkontrollfunktionen, die über Apps.
Möglich wären.
Stimmt dieses äh mit dem Diabetes, habe ich auch einen guten Bekannten, der so ein äh Diabetes, also einen Blutzuckermessgerät mit Bluetooth irgendwie am Arm, glaube ich.
Dauerhaft angebracht hat oder so so teil dauerhaft so einen Monat oder so und das kann dann über Bluetooth irgendwelche Werte abgeben und dann kann er mit dem Handy auslesen wie viel Insulin er sich jetzt spritzen müsste oder nicht,
Sind, glaube ich, also da gibt's enorme Potenziale.
Äh
Ich werde mein Argument auch nicht zu sagen, dass solche Apps nicht hilfreich sein können. Das können die natürlich. Aber es muss natürlich geprüft werden an wen alles noch dann Daten fließen, was eigentlich mit den
ermittelten äh Daten, die
Durch die App anfallen passiert und es müssen natürlich auch nachgewiesen werden, also wir nehmen ja auch keine mehr Medikamente,
also die Krankenkasse bezahlt keine Medikamente, von denen nicht nachgewiesen ist, dass die Medikamente auch tatsächlich eine Wirkung haben.
Homöopathie.
Gut. Das.
Das hätten wir. Und es gibt äh es gibt da noch also tatsächlich meine ich auch irgendwelche Meditationsapps oder so schon gesehen zu haben, wo,
Krankenkassenaussagen, hier das das fördern wir auch mit. Also ja da gibt's teilweise glaube ich relativ.
Großzügige Auslegungen von was wirksam ist oder was unterstützt wird und was nicht.
Aber ja grundsätzlich sollte man glaube ich ist es im Interesse der Krankenkassen und auch im Interesse der Versicherten, dass sie ihr Geld nur da für solche Sachen ausgeben, die irgendwie auch halbwegs was bringen.
Äh ja einmal das und das andere ist, dass es nach dem Gesetz jetzt eben auch möglich ist, dass die Krankenkassen selber mit äh Firmen,
Apps entwickeln oder dass sie äh Kapital in Firmen geben und die,
entwickeln sollen, aber das kann dann eben auch ein Flop werden und dann ist das Geld verloren und sie dürfen zwei Prozent äh ihrer Beiträge, die sie einkassieren, ähm in solche.
Risikokapitalanlagen auch geben,
und äh das sind immerhin Versichertengelder und ob man die jetzt in irgendwelche Unternehmen legen will, ist also das das ist noch mehr als nur äh die Gesundheitsapps,
die nun sinnvoll sind oder nicht, äh die verschrieben werden, sondern es ist richtig auch eine Förderung dieser Industrie.
Ist erstaunlich dürften die das eben, dürfen die in Pharmaunternehmen investieren, ne.
Nee, das nicht. Glaube ich, nee, dürfen sie nicht.
Also dann, wieso sollten die dann Apps investieren, weil man irgendwie glaubt, dass sie da das Ding zu uns Merkmal äh.
Entwickeln könnten, um sich voneinander abzugrenzen mit coolerem Service oder warum sollten die überhaupt sowas dürfen.
Viele der Apps, die es jetzt gibt, sind ja auch immer wieder mit den äh Krankenkassen entwickelt worden und sind äh also sind schon quasi gebunden an bestimmte Krankenkassen jeweils.
Ich glaub das ist die Logik die die daraus entstanden ist. Mhm.
Und das war jetzt der also der erste zentrale Teil dieses digitale Versorgungsgesetzes ähm wie würdest du das jetzt,
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt bewerten, hast du dazu in deiner ähm Auskunft im Bundestag, welcher welcher Ausschuss war das nochmal.
Gesundheitsausschuss.
Klar, logischerweise. Einfache Fragen für einhundert. Ähm wie würdest du diese Sache mit den Apps.
Zusammenfassen, also was wären, was, welche Punkte hast du da angebracht.
Ach, jetzt weiß ich gar nicht mehr genau, wo ich da drüber geredet hatte, weil das war auch äh begrenzt. Ja, doch es ging auch da drum, dass ähm einerseits
mit der Telematikinfrastruktur ja eigentlich eine große Sicherheit aufgebaut werden soll, ähm die es.
Tatsächlich möglich macht, Gesundheitsdaten zu speichern, ohne dass die ähm,
Für andere Zwecke genutzt werden können und schon so, dass sie tatsächlich ähm.
So gesichert sind, dass da wirklich keiner drankommen kann. Also.
So die äh so die Hoffnung, ja.
Genau, da gibt's noch viele Fragen dran, aber man könnte zumindest sagen, das ist die Idee, äh die dahinter steckt und wenn diese Idee dahintersteckt, dann ist es eben auf der anderen Seite nicht gut,
jetzt zu sagen, aber alle Daten, die die Krankenkassen schon haben und das ist der andere Teil jetzt. Äh, die werden jetzt gesammelt, zentral gesammelt und dann von
Spitzenverband Bund der Krankenkassen wurde ich gesammelt werden ohne irgendwelche Anonymisierung oder Pseudonymisierung, da sind alle Da.
Liegen dann schon zentral davor und die werden dann an Forschungsdatenzentrum weitergegeben. Pseudonymisiert und werden da dann,
entsprechend ganz vielen Gruppen, die Interesse haben könnten an diesen Daten auch weitergegeben,
ist natürlich geregelt, wohnt an wen und,
die weitergegeben werden dürfen, aber es ist schon eine riesige Gruppe und äh natürlich eben auch für Forschungszwecke.
Und äh äh von welchen Daten sprechen wir da? Das ist irgend also welche welche Daten stehen denn meiner Krankenkasse da zur Verfügung? Welche Daten würde dir dann entsprechend weitergeben.
Na ja.
Von der Krankenkassennummer ähm natürlich ein Sozialdaten bis hin zu allen Diagnosen, die die ja auch bekommen äh Arzneimittelverschreibungen, Behandlungen, in Krankenhäusern.
Also eigentlich haben die schon sukzessive immer mehr Daten bekommen. Früher haben die ja wirklich nur die Abrechnung gemacht.
Und äh sukzessive haben die schon immer mehr an Daten bekommen über das, was.
Behandlungen geleistet worden ist an Diagnose geleistet worden ist und welche Krankheiten diagnostiziert worden sind.
Mit anderen Worten, alles, was man sich wirklich und also was alles, was Gesundheitsdaten sensibel äh höchst privat und ähm kritisch macht, ist da mit drin.
Da ist mal erst alles mit drin in dem Gesundheitsausschuss wurde dann noch so richtig deutlich, dass es natürlich auch Interessen gibt, noch mehr Daten zu bekommen, also dass,
DE. Von der Forschung her noch die Idee besteht, dass man dann später die Patienten.
Die Daten aus den Patientenakten auch direkt zur Verfügung hat äh und bekommt, weil da könnte es ja sein, dass dann ähm Versicherte noch ihre.
Sportapps äh irgendwie und alle Daten, die da drin sind und sonstige Daten, die sie auf irgendwelchen anderen Apps noch selber sammeln, auch noch gespeichert sind,
dass das dann alles auch noch der Forschung zur Verfügung gestellt werden könnte.
Patienteneragnes im Prinzip das, was man jetzt in der Gematik äh.
Was in dieser Telematikinfrastruktur eigentlich mit dieser,
elektronischen Gesundheitskarte verbunden ist, da soll es dann eben die Möglichkeit geben, äh eine elektronische Patientenakte anzulegen und diese elektronische Patientenakte soll eben gesichert sein in der Telematik, Infrastruktur,
Da kann man auch nochmal ganz viel.
Das klammern wir jetzt gerade mal kurz aus, weil das ist schon gesetzt, ja.
Äh aber in dieser Patientenakte können die Ärzte halt ihre aber äh ihre äh.
Diagnosen speichern und,
Informationen über den Patienten in Zusammenarbeit mit dem Patienten. Im Moment heißt es ja eher, dass der Patient wirklich die Hoheit über diese Daten hat,
hat dann aber den Tat das Datenschutzrechtliche Problem, dass ähm Daten,
Ärzten geschützt sind, weil sie dann eben als unter der ärztlichen Schweigepflicht liegen. Mhm. Auf Daten, die beim Einzelnen
Bürger liegen, kann im Prinzip eine Strafverfolgungsbehörde auch zugreifen. Von daher ist dieser Schutz, äh wir haben es sind dann selber die Herren unserer Daten auch immer eine fragwürdiges Argumentation,
ähm aber in dieser Ehepatientenakte ist eben die Idee, dass dann auch andere.
Informationen aus anderen Apps damit einfließen können und dann,
wird das natürlich richtig reichhaltig. Insofern, das wäre dann noch mehr an Daten, aber zumindest gibt es bei der E-Patientenakte immer noch sehr klar die Idee, dass es.
Patient selbst oder der Versicherte entscheidet,
ob und was da gespeichert wird, während die Daten jetzt, die jetzt im Forschungsdatenzentrum gespeichert werden, äh darüber kann der Patient der Versicherte überhaupt nichts entscheiden, hat auch kein Widerspruchsrecht, sondern,
wie Daten werden von den Krankenkassen einfach insgesamt weiter Gott gegeben.
Das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht, dass sowas legal wäre. Äh scheint's ja auch nicht zu sein, sonst würde man ja kein Gesetz dafür machen, aber ähm haben wir, wieso unterliegt das nicht irgendwie der.
Also geht das überhaupt? Also ich hätte jetzt gedacht, dass eine Datenschutzgrundverordnung mich
davor bewahrt, dass beispielsweise meine Krankenkasse sagt, ach übrigens, äh deine äh dreißig Jahre Krankengeschichte, die wir jetzt hier haben, die äh laden wir jetzt in irgendeinen anderen Verband und dann
Pseudonymisieren wir die und machen daraus Forschung. Da hätte ich eigentlich gedacht, dass sowas tatsächlich verfassungswie, also irgendwas, also irgendwas muss dazu verhindern.
Ja hofft man eigentlich. Ich hoffe auch immer, also ich,
glaub ja, ehrlich gestanden, nicht so wirklich, dass äh der Bundestag da diese Woche sich gegen das Gesetz entscheidet. Mhm. Ähm
Aber ich hoffe dann schon da drauf, dass Klagen äh eingereicht werden und ich weiß auch, dass da schon welche dran sind und überlegen ähm weil es natürlich einerseits die Datenschutzgrundverordnung sieht vor, dass wir
in Paragraph neun oder in Artikel neun äh das gerade Gesundheitsdaten nicht verarbeitet werden dürfen.
Denkt man, das klingt wunderbar und klar, ähm aber da sind natürlich schon Ausnahmen vorgesehen und äh Jens Spahn bezieht sich vor allem dadrauf, auf eine Ausnahme nach Artikel dreiundzwanzig, ähm wonach.
Es äh eine Beschränkung der betroffenen Rechte gibt bei besonderen staatlichen Interessen und er meint eben die Gewährleistung hoher Qualitäts- und Sicherheitsstandstandards bei der Gesundheitsversorgung,
wichtiges Interesse, dass das alles aushebelt.
Okay, das wird er aber äh nicht per dekret entscheiden können. Da wird er nochmal äh glaube ich mit ein paar Leuten in Karlsruhe drüber diskutieren müssen, oder? Also das kann ich mir so nicht vorstellen.
Ich hoffe auch, dass das äh,
Entscheidungen gibt, aber es ist natürlich dann, es wird über eine lange Zeit. Mhm. Äh also ich glaube nicht, dass es eine Einspruchsmöglichkeit ist, die jetzt zunächst mal verhindert, dann diese Datensammlung zu machen. Und wenn in ein paar Jahren
das Verfassungsgericht entscheidet, dass das illegal ist, diese Datensammlung. Sind die schon längst über alle Berge? In der Welt und gesammelt.
Nochmal um die Daten zusammenzufassen, also zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt, nur weil wir verschiedene sonstige Pläne haben, geht's also um die Sozialdaten, das ist irgendwie alter Geschlecht und so, Wohnort, diese Daten,
dann Behandlungen und Diagnosen würde, also würde alles an diesen Spitzenverband gehen. Genau. Und der stellt sie dann, der leitet sie weiter an interessierte Stellen, die sagen,
Hier, äh, ich will mal will mal diese Daten irgendwie sehen. Gib mal.
Genau, es ist ja im Prinzip auch dieses die Daten sind jetzt in Händen der Krankenkassen.
Und noch nicht alle gesammelt zusammen, nicht zentral, ähm sondern in den einzelnen Krankenkassen und dann gehen die Daten.
Die Krankenkassen behalten die Daten, die behalten die sogar ohne Pseudonymisierung und der Staat kriegt die dann Daten dann äh pseudonymisiert ebenfalls alle.
Ähm weil das Daten, das Forschungsdatenzentrum äh ist in Händen des Bundesgesundheits. Also es angegliedert ans Bundesgesundheitsministerium.
Pseudonymisiert. Jetzt würde ich mich fragen, ähm gut digitale Gesellschaft ist eine Datenschützerorganisation,
Kann man solche Daten überhaupt? Also ja pseudonymisiert ist schon wahrscheinlich genau der der richtige Begriff anonymisieren trauen sie sich gar nicht erst zu behaupten, ne? Weil genau. Das geht gar nicht,
Das kriegst du nicht anonymisiert.
Na ja, die Steudonymisierung ist ja der geringere Schutz. Mhm. Äh und auch.
Gerade quasi wenn's um Gesundheitsdaten geht, sagen ja alle ganz klar, also alle Forscher äh Gesundheitsdaten kann man gar nicht so
anonym machen, dass die nicht wieder zurückverfolgt werden können. Es gibt schon so viele Daten. Diese Daten sind oft so äh individuell, gerade in Kombinationen, natürlich gerade bei denen, die krank sind
gibt es so spezielle Kombinationen, das ist eigentlich immer wieder herausfindbar ist.
Also zum Beispiel bei mir irgendwie, weil sie nicht wohnt in Berlin, ist so und so alt ähm hatte dann und dann eine Knieverletzung, dann gibt's irgendwie eine beispielsweise eine Aufzeichnung von mir mit Gestützen
derzeit, wo dann sofort eine äh sehr schnelle Depseudonymisierung auch stattfinden kann, weil's nicht so viele Knieverletzungen in Berlin und nicht so viele,
und dann kommen wir in Kombination mit, sagen wir mal noch einer äh Krankschreibung in einem bestimmten Zeitraum und noch ein Zahn, der mir irgendwann mal
gezogen wurde oder so, hat man ja dann quasi wahrscheinlich mit drei gesundheitlichen Merkmalen oder zwei Behandlungsmerkmalen im Zweifelsfall eine Person eindeutig identifiziert, ne.
Äh wenn du das so erzählst, denke ich, ja, wahrscheinlich geht's tatsächlich auch schon so schnell, ich habe dann immer eher noch vor Augen, dass es natürlich auch äh besondere Krankheiten gibt, also seltene Krankheiten ähm
Besonders Betroffene, die irgendwie Multi äh funktionell krank sind und da bestimmte Sachen zusammenkommen. Ich glaube, äh
an das sind dann stellen, wo überhaupt äh gar keine Frage ist, dass man ganz schnell definizieren kann.
Und dann natürlich auch klar äh entsprechende äh Diagnose sind die äh chronische Behandlungen äh oder regelmäßige Behandlungen erfordern. Äh und ja, jede, ich denke, jede Kombination, die Menschen da haben können,
glaube ich nicht, dass das irgendwie auch nur eine Person mit ähnlicher.
Krankengeschichte gibt wie eine andere.
Das klingt nach einer ziemlich ähm also man muss ja vielleicht noch wenigstens müssen wir würdigen hier ähm warum.
Also welche Vorteile versprechen die sich davon? Was, was, warum warum wollen die das tun? Sie denken ja vermutlich nicht,
so Yolo, machen wir mal voll geil, haben zwar keine Ahnung wieso, aber und das wird uns im Zweifelsfall auf die Füße fallen, aber voll die geile Idee. Wir argumentieren die, warum sie das überhaupt tun wollen oder Jens Spahn,
warum er das tun will.
Na ja,
Interesse an Gesundheitsdaten äh in einer Gesellschaft, in der Big Data sowieso eine Riesenrolle spielt, ist einfach äh völlig klar, dass man da ganz viel mit machen kann,
den unterschiedlichsten Stellen ähm und ich glaube, man muss das schon in diesem ganzen Kontext auch der Entwicklung stellen. Es,
Seit zweitausendsechs ist diese Idee mit elektronischen Gesundheitskarte ähm und dann war ja immer der Protest, gerade gegen die Idee einer äh zentralen Gesundheitsdatensammlung äh sehr stark. Das hat hier angefangen in,
den ersten Jahren danach damit, dass man
äh die Fotos nicht abgegeben hat für die Gesundheitskarten, das ist lange her. Äh und aber damit ist diese Diskussion da drum, das mit den elektronischen Patienten, Daten
oder Akte, dann Daten erfasst werden, die vielleicht nicht genügend gespeichert sind und was wird da eigentlich mitgemacht? Und was
entsteht dann nicht nur zentrale Datensammlung, ähm die ist ja da ja sehr viel diskutiert worden. Mhm. Und ähm,
In der gleichen Zeit ist sukzessive den Krankenkassen mehr Daten zugesprochen worden, die sie erhalten und damit auch auswerten können.
Und jetzt ist das eigentlich der logischste Schritt. So kann man's auch beschreiben zu sagen dann haben wir da alle Daten.
Schon mal gesammelt, zentral,
und brauchen die gar nicht über die elektronischen Patientenakte und wenn es dann irgendwann klappt, könnten wir über die elektronische Patientenakte tatsächlich noch mehr Daten bekommen,
ganz viele der zentralen Daten haben wir dann einmal zentral und können die
staatlich auswerten für irgendwelche Fragen der Gesundheitsversorgung der Bevölkerung, was ist wo zu machen? Äh, wie können,
was an Sparpotential kann es ja auch geben. Ähm auf der anderen Seite, man kann die Daten der Forschung zur Verfügung stellen und damit.
Ja auch, also im besten Fall für eine bessere Versorgung.
Forschen, aber Forschung ist eben auch nie eine, die jetzt so völlig neutral ist, sondern die entsteht natürlich auch aus gewissen Interessen.
Und man kann aus den Daten, die vorhanden sind
quasi selber dann noch wieder Forschungsfragen ableiten, weil also früher hat man ja eher Forschungsfragen gehabt und Daten genutzt, um
damit ähm die Frage zu beantworten, aber inzwischen kann man ja aus vorhandenen Daten quasi eine Frage ableiten, also,
statistisch ableiten lassen, die man dann äh was man damit machen kann. Also.
Stadtheim
gezielten Vorgehen zu sagen, wir äh forschen husten, wir brauchen Leute mit Husten, wir wollen wissen, wie lange die den haben, äh quasi eher explorativ vorzugehen und zu sagen, guck mal hier, Leute, die Husten haben,
hatten auch ja Leute, die Leute die Husten kauften, kauften auch.
Genau und dann können wir das direkt mit anbieten.
Ähm jetzt hast du.
Also ich bin immer, es gibt haben können die ein Erfolgsgeschichte ähm vorweisen.
Also gibt es irgendwas? Gibt es irgendwelche tollen äh Geschichten.
Wo man sagen würde, ja, das hätten wir ohne dieses Big Data nie herausgefunden, weil ich würde ja schon erwarten, also Gesundheit ist ja ein enorm erforschter Bereich und da gibt's jeden Tag neue,
Probleme und neue neue Lösungen und wir bekämpfen
alle möglichen Krankheiten gibt's irgendwelche spannenden Stories, die sie erzählen und sagen, guck mal hier, das haben wir mit dieser Krankheit haben wir mit Big Data in den Griff bekommen oder so.
Ähm ich glaube in,
Also ich weiß, dass es genetische Netzwerk in diesem Richtung relativ gut und viel ähm arbeitet und zusammenträgt. Ich kriege das jetzt aber nicht mehr so ganz zusammen. Es ist ja ähm der Versuch auch viel.
Bei Schwangeren schon im Vorhinein zu diagnostizieren. Ja. Was für ein,
also welche Krankheiten hat möglicherweise auch ein Fötus und dadraus Konsequenzen zu ziehen und ich glaube, da spielen Big Data Forschungen auch eine ziemlich große Rolle.
Und da spürt er bei eben diese diese ethischen Fragen, was heißt das eigentlich? Und was heißt solch eine Diagnose und was macht man damit? Äh das spielt dann ja eher keine Rolle. Mhm.
Gut, jetzt war also diese Anhörung. Ähm du hast den Eindruck, also den hat man ja leider, äh kann ich auch aus eigener Erfahrung auch sagen, als,
Sachverständiger im Bundestag relativ häufig, dass die Meinung, die man da vertritt, jetzt nicht großartig,
oder auch die Ansicht oder die Argumente, die man da vorträgt, jetzt nicht im besonderen Maß gewürdigt werden,
ist ja eher so ein bisschen, da sitzen wir jetzt alle mal ab.
Ja wobei das Layern auch noch so richtig so, dass die,
es zusammenfassen mit dem Ergebnis, also auf der Seite des Gesundheitsausschusses, dass die Experten alle das Gesetz gut finden und die Digitalisierung im Gesundheitswesen befürworten und ähm.
Sag mal außer mir,
ob jemand anders, der auch sehr kritisch sich geäußert hat, waren aber auch viele andere. Also das waren ja auch einige aus der Forschung da, äh die sich durchaus kritisch gegen das Gesetz geäußert haben. Mhm. Und wenn es dann all diese Kritik zusammengefasst wird in,
haben das alle gut gefunden. Erschreckt als ein ein wenig. Und jetzt inzwischen geht in der Presse gibt's durchaus andere Nachrichten, dass berichtet wird in dem,
Experten haben sich eher skeptisch und kritisch geäußert. Äh insofern selbst da wird ja nicht irgendwie wirklich was.
Versucht da mitzumachen oder ernst genommen oder so.
Interessant, ja, also tatsächlich eine Berichterstattung, Gesundheitsapps auf Rezept.
Zugriff auf die elektronische Patientenakte geplant, soll Patienten möglich sein, auch digitale Angebote wie die elektronische Patientenakte flächendeckend zu nutzen. Das steht uns auch heute nicht wirklich etwas im Wege.
Nun.
Gut, das du hast gesagt, also wer wurde denn da sonst noch so angehört? Also ich ich höre ja gerade mal auf den Sitzungsverlauf. Man muss ja dazu sagen, wenn so eine Anhörung stattfindet, dann dürfen ja die äh Parteien, die dort.
Vertreten sind in dem Ausschuss dürfen ja dann Sachverständige laden, von welcher Partei wurdest du geladen? Lass mich raten, sie ist keinesfalls die CDU oder SPD.
Das stimmt, weil von denen das Gesetz stammt, das heißt, wen haben die sich da eingeladen, wahrscheinlich irgendjemand von den Krankenkassen.
Genau, es sind natürlich einige Vertreter von Krankenkassen da gewesen ähm natürlich aber auch Ärztevertreter.
Schand von den großen Organisationen waren vorrangig Vertreter vorhanden und dann ein wenig äh Patientenvertreter, aber das waren.
Und die hat aber, die wurden wahrscheinlich, also.
Dann eher von der Linken.
Die werden dann eher von jemand anderem da dahinten bestellt, ne? Das ist also so funktioniert dieses Spiel, deswegen sitzen ja auch getrennt.
Wer das Gesetz durchbringen will, äh schafft natürlich im Zweifelsfall äh so nutzt die zur Verfügung stehenden Sachverständigenposten eher für ein paar,
Jubelpersa und wer in der Opposition ist, sucht natürlich die schärfsten Kritiker,
hm oder die ja kompetentesten Kritiker auf jeden Fall die Kritiker ähm und dann wird das äh wird die Sitzung da durchgesessen, dann kann jeder seine äh kann jede Organisation oder jede Sachverständige da ihr,
Ihre Ansichten zu Protokoll geben, ähm,
wenn man, wenn man genug Zeit bekommt, kann man das, kann man auch noch eine schriftliche Stellungnahme einreichen. Das klang jetzt nicht so, als hättest du da viel Zeit zur Vorbereitung gehabt.
Ähm wir hatten vorher schon zu dem Gesetz eine Stellungnahme erarbeitet. Ah, okay. Und ähm hatten die schon veröffentlicht und
Das hat glaube ich auch eher dazu geführt, dass wir dann eingeladen worden. Ähm insofern doch, die habe ich dann auch da nochmal eingereicht und jetzt hatte ich auch mal erst den Effekt, dass es dann eben zumindest der Gesundheitsausschuss,
ähm das hat die Stellungnahme einmal ganz bekommt
aber natürlich kann man nicht wirklich damit rechnen, dass sie es lesen oder sich damit wirklich auseinandersetzen, sondern das hat eben auch viel so eine Legitimitäts äh.
Effekt, dass man dann die an alle angehört hat und sie müssen das heutzutage machen, aber es hat nicht wirklich irgendwie den Effekt, dass man sich wirklich miteinander auseinandersetzt und das müsste ja eigentlich auch vorher passieren und nicht erst,
wenn das Gesetz drei Wochen später dann durch den Bundestag verabschiedet werden soll.
Wir haben jetzt Dienstag, den fünften November und du gehst also davon aus, dass am Donnerstag, den siebten November ist die Abstimmung im Bundestag. Ähm festgelegt oder.
Für für neun Uhr. Morgen. Am Donnerstag ist es schon terminiert.
Okay und dann wäre das wird äh im Zweifelsfalle ähm so beschlossen. Ähm was steht denn im Gesetz drin, bis wann das also wann werden denn dann meine Daten?
Ersten ersten zwei zwanzig zwanzig. Ja ja, das äh das Gesetz soll eben ist ganz klar dieses Jahr noch verabschiedet werden, es soll ja auch dieses Jahr im.
Ende November oder Anfang Dezember äh noch durch den Bundesrat und dann äh soll es auf jeden Fall zum ersten ersten.
Gültig sein.
Das heißt, sofort umgesetzt werden. Für diejenigen, die sich dagegen wehren wollen, ist es nicht mit der Abstimmung am siebten November getan. Es lohnt sich dann noch den Druck auf den Bundesrat zu erhöhen.
Wie sind da die ähm Entscheidungs ähm also wie viele Länder muss man da überzeugen? Äh für eine Ablehnung oder für eine für ein.
Für eine extra Runde des Gesetzes.
Es müssten ja eigentlich acht neun Länder dagegen stimmen. Mhm. Ähm, ich hab das ehrlich gestanden jetzt gar nicht ausgerechnet, ob da irgendeine Chance ist. Mhm. Es war erstaunlich, wie differenziert und klar die Kritik,
war, die sie jetzt schon geäußert haben, das heißt im Bundesrat äh müssen schon,
Leute und oder Länder so intensiv dran sein, ähm dass sie sich genauer damit beschäftigt haben und und eine kritische Haltung haben. Ähm die Verbraucherzentrale Sachsen zum Beispiel hat,
an ihrer Regierung geschrieben, dass sie doch bitte dem nicht zustimmen sollten. Mhm. Ähm,
Also insofern gibt es das und das müsste man nur richtig verstärken und ob das noch gelingen kann ähm die Grünen haben sich ja.
Bisher auch eher sehr vorsichtig geäußert und jetzt eigentlich ähm.
Letztes Wochenende plötzlich nochmal sehr klar gegen das Gesetz geäußert. Von daher könnte man natürlich versuchen, all die Bundesländer, wo die Grünen mit in der Regierung sind
nochmal zu überzeugen, dass die
dagegen stimmen oder zumindest sich enthalten oder sowas. Mhm. Aber das muss man dann wirklich nochmal sehr genau durchrechnen und gucken, ob's da eine Chance geben kann.
Und dann ist der nächste, dann wäre der nächste Schritt äh kann ich irgendwie eine eine Notfallverfügung
äh welche welche Hebel hätten die Datenschützer, Datenschutzbeauftragten der Länder oder des Bundes so etwas so ein so ein Risikoprojekt zu stoppen.
Auch da ist jetzt äh die Chance der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte hat sich auch bisher,
also gegen den ersten Entwurf. Klar ausgesprochen, aber nicht mehr so klar, öffentlich gegen den jetzt vorliegende Gesetz und hat jetzt aber auch am Wochenende,
zum ersten Mal klar gesagt, dass er eine kritische Stellungnahme dazu abgegeben hat und das nicht für hm,
umsetzbar hält und Datenschutzrechtlich ähm in Ordnung
Insofern, es gibt jetzt noch, ob er die, diese, also dieses Potential an Kritik, was jetzt plötzlich entsteht, das ist erst dieses Wochenende entstanden äh und das kann ich auch noch schwer einschätzen, welche Wirkung das jetzt eigentlich noch entfalten kann.
Okay. Ähm dann denke ich.
Haben wir den Sachverhalt bis zum jetzigen Moment ganz gut geklärt, es geht weiter mit dem Bundesrat. Wir haben noch äh den Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten Ulrich Kälber, der hier noch ein Wort mitreden kann und dann im Zweifelsfall würde ich, also
bei so etwas.
Wenn es da keine signifikanten Verbesserungen gibt, würde ich erwarten, dass da eine der üblichen Organisationen ähm Zweifelsfall versucht, eine Beschwerde dagegen zu erheben und das Ganze in,
Karlsruhe zumindest noch einmal prüfen zu lassen. Habt ihr da schon Bestrebungen von der digitalen Gesellschaft oder wie wie setzt ihr wie seht ihr diesen.
Wie seht ihr dieses Thema.
Also ich fänd's richtig gut, wenn eine Klage eingereicht wird. Ich finde, man muss bloß auch prüfen, eben, ob man es noch irgendwie
quasi den Aufbau der dieser zentralen Datensammlung verhindern kann, also ob irgendwelche Möglichkeiten gibt,
Gefahr im Verzug und das muss jetzt mal erst außer Kraft gesetzt werden. Da bin ich aber juristisch zu unsicher, um zu sagen, ob's sowas,
sonst muss man halt normal die Klage zumindest einreichen. Wir sind einfach als Verein so klein, dass wir es wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich schaffen. Wir sind
mit anderen Vereinen im Gespräch, dass man es machen sollte und müssen halt gucken, wer federführend übernehmen kann.
Ja, denke ich. Also das klingt auch nach einer, also nach Karlsruhe zieht man ja nicht.
Am Nachmittag klingt nach etwas, wo man sich als mehrere Datenschützervereine oder vielleicht gibt's da auch entsprechende Vereine aus dem Gesundheitsbereich.
Genetisches Netzwerk, ähm,
Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte, Digital-Courage hat sicherlich auch ein Interesse Interesse an dem Thema, dass man sich da hoffentlich irgendwie zusammentun könnte. Ähm.
Ich denke vielleicht würde ich noch abschließend sagen es kommt natürlich immer darauf an wie so etwas gemacht wird.
Und ich persönlich würde als Bürger äh und als äh Mensch mit einer Gesundheit, an der mir gelegen ist, welche jetzt auch nicht vollständig dagegen sperren, bestimmte Daten ähm zur.
Zur Verfügung zu stellen. Ich hätte aber, glaube ich, und das scheint mir hier der Kern der Angelegenheit zu sein. Ich hätte relativ konkrete Vorstellungen davon.
Dass ich mein Einverständnis dazu gebe. Ich hätte relativ klare Vorstellungen davon, ähm welche Anforderungen ich hätte an.
Die Weitergabe, Nutzungsrechte, Verwendungszwecke, Löschfristen und sonstiges dieser Daten,
Und irgendwie so ein Fulltake, gib mal, gib mal äh Onkel Spahn und dann wird's irgendwie verteilt und jeder, der irgendwie ein Interesse hat, kann sich die Sachen holen. Ich glaube, das würde nämlich nicht lange dauern
irgendwie hält, dort Google dot com sagt, hey, wir haben schöne, bunte Bilderchen, die wir dir malen können und das scheint mir hier.
Viel zu riskanter Dammbruch zu sein, als der sich den mal eben nebenbei noch kurz vor Weihnachten hinnehmen würde. Und da wäre mir schon äh irgendwie.
Daran gelegen, dass es hier eine sinnvollere rechtliche Grundlage für geben würde, wo ein paar Leute sich darüber Gedanken gemacht haben und ähm ja, für auch wirklich eine Reihe an,
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen, die sich gegen Missbrauch und sonstiges stellen.
Ähm,
Ja, also einerseits, wir gehen ja bisher wirklich davon aus, dass es eine informierte Zustimmung geben muss. Datenverarbeitung sind wir immer von Host gegangen und war eigentlich das, was so datenschutzrechtlich,
bei uns immer selbstverständlich. Ja. Und mit der Datenschutzgrundverordnung eigentlich noch verstärkt worden ist. Ähm.
Und natürlich gibt es schon lange Bestrebungen das auszuhebeln, also die nationale Gehorte, das so ein Forschungsprojekt über,
langen Zeitraum, ich glaube über dreißig Jahre äh auch Daten erheben. Ähm die brauchen natürlich die Zustimmung derer, die sie untersuchen wollen, äh aber auch da war es schon, dass die,
das versucht haben so zu machen, dass es nur so ein breiten Zustimmung gibt und die Daten dann für alle Forschungsprojekte, die die für sinnvoll halten, äh, weitergegeben wird und nicht mehr einzeln zugestimmt werden muss
Aber diese Aushebelung des Datenschutzes ist ja gerade hat das,
Gern Spahn, Bundesgesundheitsminister, ähm dass äh Implantat, Register äh Einführungsgesetz erlassen, ähm,
Da geht es nur um diejenigen, die irgendwelche Implantate bekommen.
Und auch da ist die Möglichkeit der datenweit, also der äh Weitergabe der Daten für dieses ähm.
Implantatregister ähm,
ausgeschlossen worden, alle, die ein Implantat bekommen, deren Daten werden in diesem Register erfasst und es geht nicht dadrum, dass die Implantate erfasst werden,
Was ja auch noch einen Sinn haben könnte, weil man zum Beispiel, wenn sich herausstellt, dass,
irgendwelche Implantate schädlich sind, man weiß wer die die Implantate bekommen hat.
Heil handeln kann, aber es werden dann halt die gesamten Gesundheitsdaten auch in diesem Fall erfasst.
Keine Möglichkeit geschaffen, dem zu widersprechen ähm und da war die Begründung, dass bisher neunzig Prozent derjenigen, ähm die Implantate bekommen haben,
dem zugestimmt haben, dass ihre Daten zu Forschungszwecken benutzt werden dürfen. Aber man bräuchte die zehn Prozent, die nicht zugestimmt haben eben auch noch.
Wofür braucht man ein Implantate-Register? Gehen die verloren? Also mir ist das gerade unklar, warum sollte man es überhaupt? Warum wofür braucht man das?
Also es gab ja dieses Brustimplantat äh Frankreich damals zum Beispiel und dann ähm,
dass das gefährlich war und gesundheitsschädigen und da könnte man eben sagen, okay, äh das ist, es kann tatsächlich sinnvoll sein, dass man einen Register hat,
solche Implantate und wer die bekommen hat, welche Implantate bekommen hat, äh, registriert. Äh und das.
Wieder, wenn man Rückrufe ist, ja.
Genau, Rückruf klingt super. Ähm.
Aber also es ist ja auch tatsächlich, es gibt ja immer sinnvolle Nutzungen, aber es ist eben auch soweit ausgedehnt, dass die Gesamtheit gesamten Gesundheitsdaten äh erfasst werden und damit Forschung gemacht werden kann.
Also alles was ansonsten auch was dran in der Folge äh in Folgeuntersuchungen erfasst wird an Daten wird in diesem Register miterfasst.
Auch da, ich meine, diese Argumentation, dass zehn Prozent ihre Daten nicht zur Verfügung gestellt haben, leuchtet mir einfach nicht ein, dass das ein Grund ist.
Ähm für die Forschung.
Das war so bei neunzig Prozent der Daten ist zur Spitze und die letzten zehn Prozent kann man dann eben, denke ich, auch drauf verzichten, oder?
Würde ich mal von ausgehen, aber das macht so deutlich, es geht wirklich dadrum, alle Daten zu kriegen und dass diese Zustimmung völlig auszuheben.
Okay, dann würde ich sagen, wir verfolgen das weiterhin. Ich bin froh, dass wir dieses Thema jetzt noch,
mit einer eigenen Sendung würdigen konnten, weil das,
immer wieder und ich nehme, ich stelle das immer wieder fest, dass diese Strategie mal so ein Thema schnell unterm Radar kurz durchzuballern, ähm immer wieder und immer häufiger ähm Anwendung findet.
Und immer häufiger auch echt Gefahr läuft zu gelingen. Ich erinnere mich an das Ende der.
Letzten Legislaturperiode, wo wir quasi einmal äh Flächen.
Bombardiert wurden mit irgendwie Grundrechtseinschrittsgrundrechtseinschränkenden Gesetzen,
Und insofern bin ich froh,
wir hier jetzt auch nochmal schnell einen Blick drauf geworfen haben und ja hoffentlich noch es schaffen durch Protest oder äh informierte äh Verbesserungen und Ergänzungen.
Diesem Gesetz entgegenzutreten oder diesen Bestrebungen entgegenzutreten, das hier nicht ähm schnell.
Und hasst dich irgendwelche Fakten geschaffen werden, die uns vielleicht als Bürgerinnen und Bürger nachher alle nochmal leid tun werden.
Das würde ich mir auch sehr wünschen, ja.
Dann danke ich dir, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast, dieses Thema nochmal mit uns zu besprechen. Ich wünsche euch,
erfolgreichen und angenehmen netzpolitischen Abend. Ähm, ich werde die Zeit wahrscheinlich eher damit verbringen, die Sendung zu schneiden und zu veröffentlichen und
dann wäre es noch mein Anliegen dem Dominik herzlich zu danken, dem Dietrich äh herzlich zu danken und alles Gute zu wünschen und natürlich auch noch mein Dank an.
Ersin und Larissa. Damit hören wir uns dann.
Zeitnah im Logbuch wieder, vielleicht dann auch mal wieder mit einer guten Nachricht, Ecke, herzlichen Dank.
Herzlichen Dank Linus. Ciao.
Ciao ciao.